foreign
Luna is in Salt Lake City Utah hi Luna
welcome to the Ramsey Show
how you doing better than I deserve
what's up
uh can you hear me all right yes
okay
um so I'm gonna try and make this as
short as possible but I'm 29. I have a
fire under my butt to go back to school
and I'm currently one year through you
know undergraduate it's going to be four
years so I'm it's gonna be really a
useless degree unless I go to graduate
school because it's for a Veterinary
doctor degree
and I'm looking at it and it looks like
I'm going to be able to pay for it uh
you're gonna hate this it's going to be
all on loans but I don't even make over
like
the threshold to make
you know pay taxes
so I I make next to nothing my family
all live paycheck to paycheck but the
one Saving Grace here is like my
grandparents they have a trust and they
say that I have 10 of it
when they die and I'm wondering like
is it possible to borrow from a trust or
get it early or what what can I do
because I'm just looking to pay for my
living expenses through college
what were you doing before you went on
this adventure
um I really tried to have a family life
but they
they all kind of left
but who's they your husband your kids
yes
I don't have any kids I've got cats but
um
yeah I I was married for a short time
divorced but
um
my life kind of fell apart for a while
and I've put it back together and I
finally have like a passion and a
purpose and I'm like I said I've got a
fire under my butt to go back to school
make something of myself
but I'm just you know there's there's
not a lot of money out there for
students unless you borrow and that's
not a good option but can I challenge
something can I challenge something real
quick
yeah
um you don't gotta go make something of
yourself you already got worth right now
yeah okay
and you got I think that fire under your
butt honestly is how burned you are
because you looked at somebody and you
said I do and he said I do and then he
left
well I mean that's that's not something
that I'm really
focusing on here in the future that's
kind of
past has passed but now like I did
so caught up in your throat you can
hardly speak that's right there's a
great quote that says you may be through
the past but the past isn't through with
you and if you don't heal from that
where you can talk about it and think
about it without your body getting
overcome then it's going to haunt you
and what it's going to do it's gonna
shoot you like a rocket ship into some
life-altering decisions like getting 250
or 300 000 in the hole
and not knowing what what what day what
what direction is up or down
and maybe not even finishing
and getting the DVM that's right not
everybody that starts that school
finishes vet school not everybody that
finishes vet school passes their boards
and becomes a veterinarian
and so
um it's harder than medical schools from
what I hear yeah it is one of my friends
at this event says when you're in
medical school you only have to learn
one set of anatomy he said I have to
learn a whole bunch of them
so he makes fun of doctors and it's very
difficult and uh intellectually
difficult and uh and you love animals
obviously it becomes an emotional
process too so Luna the answer to your
question is no you cannot borrow on a
trust unless the trust has
written into it the uh that option I'm
gonna bet you that this one does not
and uh can they release who is the trust
your grandparents formed the trust for
their money to leave to their grandkids
if their grandkids and their children
yeah okay and how much is in the trust
um
I think it was down a little bit right
now but it was like 2.7 million dollars
so your parts like 270 000 so it would
fund you going to school okay so if you
talk to your grandfather he could just
choose to take you out of the trust
and take 270 000 and pay for your school
and you no longer would be in the trust
okay uh he could choose to do that
legally uh you want me to tell you what
I think is going to happen you're not
going to like it
well yeah but I think your grandfather
loves you I think your grandfather loves
you and he's going to see how fragile
you are and that you're probably not in
really good emotional shape right now to
go take on something like the Battle of
vet school
it's going to take a lot more strength
than you've exhibited in this call to do
that and I'm not picking on you honey I
think you've been hurt
and you're still hurting and I want you
to have some healing and be going at vet
school from strength rather than from
weakness and I gotta feel on your
grandpa might say that does that sound
like something he might say
maybe but I also skipped over the part
where I went to like therapy and I was
in the hospital for a while doing
inpatient and outpatient like and and
here's the thing here's the thing
sweetie I'm pretty well balanced now
I've been a I've I've been a I've taught
doctoral students I've walked them
through their dissertation I've worked
with law students I've worked with
medical students like
I need you to hear what Dave's saying
that probably the greatest gift you
could give yourself is to get a one if
not two jobs where you are working
really close with animals because it's
what you love
um and do that hour in hour out day
after day week after week month after
month and make sure you love this and
for two or three years and let yourself
have some distance because
um the lady we're talking to is having
trouble going through the conversation
much less through three years of vet
school
this is two guys who both love our dogs
and we love our vets we want you to win
I want you to win I'm not trying to be a
dream killer I'm trying to be a
nightmare killer and I got a feeling if
your Grandpa loves you and if he's wise
he will deny your request
not because he's being mean but because
he's going to hear and see what we're
hearing and seeing that's my guess now
again you're just a radio show we've
only talked to you for two minutes honey
but you sound very hurt and very fresh
and very raw and talking to you and
that's not a that's not saying you
haven't done hard work already but
you've got some more you've got some
more healing to do is what it sounds
like and if we're wrong we're wrong you
go do what you want to do honey uh
you're a grown-up you're allowed to do
what you want to do you called us and
we're going to tell you the truth
because we love you here's a here even
if it's not what you want to hear I'm
going to give you this analogy
um I've met with countless people over
the years who are sick and tired of
being overweight
and they say today is the day like that
I start
none of those folks are going to be
successful if the next day they start
running a marathon that's not how that
works
they start walking around their
neighborhood they hire a personal
trainer and slowly start lifting weights
it's a slow gradual process it's going
to take time because you have to heal
you have to change your entire way of
doing life and to build your muscle tone
that's right you got to build your body
and so
um I want you to hear me a day save say
later not now yeah this is not you can't
remember this number not never not right
now not right now and you're going to
know a whole lot more about you and a
whole lot more about this career path if
you'll go do what John said and that's
become a vet tech and just go in there
and love animals every day and get paid
and pay your bills and get paid and love
animals and pay your bills and get paid
and smile and get in the morning read
your Bible and sit on the back porch
with a cup of coffee and watch the sun
come up and know that everything's going
to be okay and you do that a little
while longer and you know the past will
be a little bit more in your rear view
mirror and again I'm not discounting
or putting down all the work you've done
so far the hospital the therapists all
that I'm just telling you reflecting
back to you what we heard in three
minutes on the radio honey and also I
got a buddy
yeah yeah everyone who runs a vet clinic
and he's always talking about they're
trying to hire good vets and so I can
even see a scenario where you are a vet
tech for a couple years and some vet
looks at you and says I'll help you go
through school I'll pay for it if um you
sign a five-year deal with me or
something and so yeah man you may figure
something out there ding ding and the
situation might change with the trust
over time
if your grandparents passed the 10 could
be coming to you while you're doing all
of this instead of you going up to your
eyeballs in debt in this situation and
then maybe not able to play through